a delightful opportunity to be here this
is definitely one of the shortest uh
travel trips that I've ever had to give
a talk because my office is just across
the street and this is a familiar space
because we ran the human computer
interaction seminar in here last year so
it's great to be here today and as Mark
said I'm one of the faculty members in
the mechanical engineering department
where I run the shape lab but I'm also
very much involved with the Stanford
human computer interaction group as well
and so today I'm going to be talking
about our work sort of at the
intersection between uh yeah human
computer interaction and Robotics and
mechatronic systems and thinking about
how do we really enable people to
interact in much richer ways I also have
to apologize I had a hand procedure done
earlier today and basically it I thought
it was going to be not as painful as it
was and so I'm a little bit more under
the weather than normal so you'll have
to believe that this would be even more
exciting and normally So speaking of
hands I've long been impressed by you
know the the dexterous ability of our
hands to allow us to manipulate the
world and and certainly having recently
had some uh you know injury for my wrist
uh I that's become even more clear to me
how important our hands are for
manipulating things in the world and
really just the amazing complexity of
our hands and the way in which we're
able to interact so gracefully and
dexterously to achieve really skillful
manipulation such as hear sculpting in
clay but all of our everyday tasks as
well but to me what's really exciting
about the hand and manipulation is the
role of manipulation in terms of our
cognitive our cognition as well and so
physical interaction is very important
for not just you know physical
manipulation for the sake of changing
the world but also for us to express our
thoughts as you see me gesturing like
this this but also for us to better
understand information so so there's
been a lot of studies that have looked
at how children when they learn with
abacai for example are Abacus in plural
abacai that they actually learn math
concepts differently and better than if
they learn them just on paper and pencil
and so there's something behind this
idea of embodied cognition that's
actually quite important and we see that
not just in terms of education but
really in terms of very specialized
domains as well so for example this is a
photograph of urban planners and
Architects and what we see there is
there's this you know basically Rich
interplay between the physical models
that they're building space and the ways
in which people want to interact as well
and so physical and spatial form can
really help us better understand and
solve problems and very complex ones in
the architecture domain but but many
other domains as well and the big kind
of reason behind this is that spatial
manipulation as I kind of highlighted
before really AIDS in spatial cognition
these two things are very tightly
coupled together and one of the great
professors that we have had at Stanford
Barbara traversity has done a lot of
work as well looking into the role that
spatial manipulation plays in our
cognition and kind of The evolutionary
basis for this as well so she has a
great new book out called Mind in motion
that I highly recommend you take to look
at but in many ways this is because
cognition and perception are very much
coupled together through action and
we've evolved over a long period of time
to really benefit from the way that we
can manipulate the world to better
understand it and these things are
tightly coupled together this is even
more important when we think about
access to information and so for example
these physical representations uh you
know can be really important for people
with different abilities so here's a
picture of a blind student at the
Perkins School for the Blind in in the
the Boston area looking or feeling
rather a double helix model and this is
something that would be very hard for us
to explain through words but by being
able to touch feel and manipulate it
they can you know much more easily
understand and this is a tactile model
of Berlin's Museum Island again this
type of spatial information might be
very hard for us to uh to convey through
text alone but by allowing people to
directly access it through touch and
through our haptic sense we can much
more readily access it but if we look at
the ways in which we traditionally
interact with Computing and with
information not much has changed since
30 years ago in in some ways for for the
ways in which we interact and
historically it's been the case that we
really haven't been able to leverage our
sense of touch in that and if we look
towards you know basically newer
interfaces for interactions such as in
virtual reality a lot of times we really
get these benefits of spatial
interaction where here I can move around
and interact and collaborate with
someone else but when we reach out to
feel something or touch something we're
not really receiving any meaningful
feedback and so one of the key questions
that I've been interested in as well as
many other people in the field of haptic
interfaces is you know what if we could
reach out and touch the void and so
during my PhD at the MIT media lab we
were really interested in trying to
merge between the physical and the
digital world and bring the that sense
of physical touch into the real world so
that if we were you know two people
working around a workstation we could
look at each other see each other and
also directly interact with a surface
and be able to uh to feel it and so let
me show you what that might look like so
here's a picture of a a new type of
happy display we call this a shape
display that we developed at the MIT
media lab with my advisor PhD advisor
Hiroshi ishi and my colleague Daniel
lightinger where we could you know
really reach out and sort of sculpt with
digital clay or we could reach out and
new interface elements could appear that
have the correct affordances and
ergonomics for how we might want to
interact or we could render different
types of 3D models in in sort of real
time and be able to again see them in 3D
but also touch them so this type of
display had been sort of considered
before by a number of other researchers
but here we were able to really look at
what are these meaningful interaction
techniques and start to look at some
example applications as well so this was
a project that we worked on with Tony
Tain who was a firm formerly a
practicing urban planner and as I said
before you know the spatial models that
urban planners and architect takes build
are often very important for how they
think and consider this space but
they're you know basically they would
make one set of foam models and then not
be able to change anything and so here
we can in real time change the models
but also have other simulations that we
can load on top of that and be able to
you know edit manipulate and
collaboratively work together so this
sort of gives a hint for what this new
type of interaction with what we call
shape changing displays might be alike
and so when I came to Stanford I guess
now seven ish years ago or so I started
the Sheep lab to really deeper
investigate these types of systems but
also work on some other areas as well
and so in our group we've been working
on new types of haptic displays like the
ones that I've shown here and that's
really what I'm going to spend the most
of today talking about but I quickly
wanted to mention two other areas that
our group has also been working on as
well and that are kind of related to the
robotics areas and so the next area that
we've also been thinking about is this
new notion of ubiquitous robotic
interfaces and really this idea Harkens
back to someone who maybe some of you
know of but Mark Weiser who sort of
started the field of ubiquitous
Computing that we really live in today
where there's you know in this room
around us many different sensors and
actual or sorry many different sensors
and displays there's probably you know
at least a hundred if not a thousand
computers in this room right now and so
the question that we had is sort of what
would it be like in the future if we
could have actuation and Robotics be
embedded in our environment as easily as
uh the the Computing and displays that
we have today and so with my PhD student
who's now a professor at Simon Fraser
University Lawrence Tim we created this
platform of small mobile robots that we
could then explore and again here we can
have them display information like this
but we also looked at ways in which they
could be embedded in our environment
like on our desk move around to display
information when we need but also
manipulate things in the environment or
go about you know remotely sensing
different things as well and we think
this kind of opens up some interesting
opportunities to think about again where
does this line between a robot and
environment end and so that that's
something that we're also quite
interested in and kind of intersects a
lot with human robot interaction and the
last area that we're doing work in is in
shape changing robotics which is
something that Mark highlighted before
and a lot of that has to do with
enabling technologies that we are
looking at to to make shape changing
displays and also shape changing robots
and so if you think back to that first
example haptic display that I showed
that is sort of like a 2.5 D surface
display one of the things that we had
been thinking about is how might we sort
of make full 3D shape changing displays
this is sort of the Holy Grail of some
of our work in terms of thinking about
oh how could we actually you know feel a
whole entire dolphin and actually have
it be able to change shape between
different surfaces and so as one of my
pH forever PhD students Zach Hammond and
a collaborate of ours and Nathan
yusovich from Allison okamora's group
we're trying to think about how might we
make this Vision a reality and so we got
inspired by uh basically balloon animals
to think about new ways that we might
approach this and the interesting thing
about balloon animals right is that you
have start out with something very
simple like essentially a inflated tube
and then we can pinch it at certain
points knot it together and basically
create many different shapes out of the
same you know simple balloon idea and so
we tried to bring this idea to the field
of Soft Robotics where we could have uh
basically an inflated beam and as
opposed to relying on pumps to move and
actuate different areas what if we
created a pinch point in that beam and
then what if we could move that pinch
point round and then basically what that
allows us to do is create some type of
system that can really dramatically
change shape by putting a robot roller
node on that surface and driving it
around and then creating what we call
sort of this idea of a ISO parametric
type of robot where we have a fixed
length of inflated tube but then we can
change kind of the the overall basically
geometry even though it has a fixed
topology and so here is you know one
element inside that but we can place
these together through other kinematic
connections to create some type of
tetrahedral robot that we can then
basically address robot that we can then
really dramatically change shape and
again we get these benefits of having
this constant volume of air that we
don't need to really pump around but
instead using motors to move these pinch
points or Buckle points around and so
here's an example of what those types of
basically trust robots could look like
and so this is you know a fairly large
device about you know this this size and
it's able to pretty dramatically change
shape and move around and this is all
shown in real time and so it can you
know locomote by basically doing some
type of punctuated rolling change its
shape and move around but it can also uh
it can also drill ahead and manipulate
objects as well so it can use the
geometry of of itself to basically grasp
an object and then be able to pick it up
and actually do some interesting in hand
manipulation as well and so we think
that this kind of idea of having these
large shape-changing truss robots has
some interesting applications in terms
of thinking about new ways that we could
be able to locomote manipulate and also
use the shape change to afford different
types of interaction in the environment
and so we've also done some work to look
at the the modeling and kinematic
control and planning of this as well so
Zach in our group did a lot of work on
grasp optimization planning with these
types of robot and we have a
collaboration with Matt schwader looking
at decentralized control of these types
of systems as well
um so I won't go into too many details
uh in that area uh today but I just
wanted to give you kind of an overview
of some of the different things that
we're working on our in our group but
today I'm really going to focus on these
types of shape changing or haptic
displays and I'm going to start out by
talking a little bit about our the way
in which we approach these problems and
really the way in which we like to think
about this in our group is really
focusing very deeply on specific
applications and needs working with
domain experts in those areas and then
trying to learn more about what are the
enabling Technologies or the
requirements for the enabling
Technologies to actually make these
systems work and then that kind of feeds
back into other applications and needs
and we think this is a kind of a nice
Paradigm for working on it uh you know
basically new technology to make these
things possible so I wanted to start by
talking about two vignettes of specific
applications that we've been working on
and the first is in card design and the
second is in meeting making accessible
to sort of highlight some of the
challenges in making these systems
actually useful and so many of you might
be familiar with you know car design in
general and have seen these types of
clay models that uh basically in
industrial designers and human factors
experts create to create to prototype
and test car designs and so we had been
reached or we have been working with
Volkswagen who's trying to transition
from mating these clay models which end
up Crossing you know something on the
order of a hundred thousand dollars per
clay model so it's very expensive and
time consuming to make those and moving
instead to using virtual reality to
prototype and test at scale especially
in terms of working with different
stakeholders that they care about as
well as the human factors aspects of
like the interior of the car as well and
so what they're trying to do is
basically transition from this you know
very physical style of doing things to
now move into the virtual reality
systems but what they found is that for
example in the case of the interior of
the car design what they call the
seating buck and the human machine
interaction basically they'll be able to
load up different car designs and
virtual reality and then they have these
very fancy seating butts to adjust the
position and height and steering wheel
position to basically create any
different kind of car but then you go
and reach out and try to touch the HDMI
the human machine interface part of it
and the dashboard and basically you you
know again Reach Out And Touch nothing
or touch air and so one thing that they
end up doing is creating these you know
basically machined or milled foam models
that they can then place inside this
seating Buck to then be able to go ahead
and test but it turns out it takes a
long time for them to actually be able
to create these foam models they can't
switch something change thing on on
demand
Etc and so that we had this idea of what
if we could create uh you know
interactive seating Buck uh basically
simulator where we could create this you
know basically surface that we could
change in real time to allow us to
explore basically the different HDMI
interactions and some of the ergonomic
issues as well so we started out working
with them on this concept and trying to
create a new generation of our tactile
displays to be able to do this so this
was led by Alexa Sue and so she created
this you know basically this is about
the smallest that you can do with kind
of like low-cost off-the-shelf DC
actuators so this has a direct drive
between them with the lead screw and you
know many many actuators and we made
this modular so you can stack them
together and we also uh you know looked
at the integration with this as well as
in in virtual reality and then we
brought it back to our collaborators at
Volkswagen particularly like the
industrial designers and the you know
human factor Specialists and they sort
of said oh hey this is great we like the
idea but you know wouldn't it be great
if these could be a lot higher
resolution and and much cheaper so you
know in terms of the the types of things
that they're looking for that we're not
still there with this technology
um and again oh wouldn't it be nice if
you know we could create many of these
not just you know basically this device
here across something like six thousand
dollars in Parts uh to create so
wouldn't it be nice if we could you know
basically have this be higher resolution
and you know basically a much larger in
steel and lower in cost so those were
some of the the feedback that we got
which sort of makes sense in some ways
but then I wanted to highlight another
application area that we've been
thinking about that also informed some
of these other challenges and so this is
in the area of still computer-aided
design and this idea of making making
accessible and so many of you are
probably very familiar with the The
Mating movement or major movement that
kind of has gone on over the past 15 or
20 years
and basically you know one of the great
things about that is that it's really
empowered a lot of people and and served
as a great way to involve more people in
stem education but that doesn't mean
that all people are unable to do that
and particularly a lot of the tools that
we use uh for making uh especially in
terms of computer-aided design are not
accessible to people that are blind or
visually impaired and so those people
have historically been excluded from
those areas and so while 3D printing can
be very helpful in terms of supporting
accessible education through the use of
creating tactile Graphics or other types
of materials that blind people can touch
and feel there's really this lack of
authoring tools for blind people for
them to be able to be the designers and
Engineers themselves and so the big
problem with these uh essentially with
these systems that exist for
computer-aided design is that they're
all based on basically graphical user
interfaces where you have to directly
manipulate uh with a mouse and a
keyboard as well as the computer screen
to be able to select and control many
features and the that's really great for
people that are cited right we've moved
Beyond command line interfaces to this
direct direct manipulation type of
interface but for someone that's blind
and visually impaired basically the main
way that they interact with computers is
through different types of screen
readers which basically provide audio
feedback and so how might we think about
ways in which they could still be able
to use this so there is some work on
using text-based editors for creating
geometry so for example openscad is a
computed solid geometry modeler where
you write basically in a declarative
programming language to define the
geometry and there's been some great
work at the dimensions project at the
New York Public Library Chansey Fleet
there in terms of basically using that
for people that are blind or visually
impaired to write code to then be able
to 3D print something but if you can
imagine and you've used a 3D printer you
know they're not particularly fast and
so basically you write sub code and then
while we you know people that are cited
would be able to you know instantly see
the changes that we're making someone
that's blind and visually impaired would
have to basically use a 3D printer wait
somewhere between an hour to you know 10
hours to find out oh the change that I
made was that exactly what I wanted and
so one of the questions we've been
asking is how might Dynamic tactile
feedback uh you know support this type
of interaction and so again my former
PhD student Alexa Sue as well as some
members from the Blind and Visually
Impaired community in the Bay Area son
Kim who's an access technology
specialist at the vista center for the
blind as well as Josh Miele who is an
amazing blind engineer and researcher
who's now at Auto at a Amazon working on
accessibility there we all work together
to create and co-design with other blind
makers a tool that allows people to use
these types of tactile shaped displays
we've been talking about to in real time
have that feedback so here basically
you're able to write code in open S Cad
and then in real time be able to touch
and feel the geometry and sort of be
able to understand what it is and so one
of the questions that we had and then
3D print the design so one of the
questions we had is you know what are
the types of interactions that we need
to Port from these direct manipulation
interfaces that are really essential for
basically helping blind and visually
impaired people understand that so we
did a lot of different co-design
sessions to try to understand what these
challenges are and one of the things
that's interesting it turns out that
section views are even more important uh
you know basically for blind and
visually impaired people than for in our
you know cited based CAD systems because
you know essentially uh you know there's
no notion of transparency in these types
of displays you're basically just
feeling the top surface of the convex
hole or whatever so you can't have any
way to display at least with these
displays this notion of transparency
which we rely on a lot
so we have some you know basically
promising interactions that we think are
possible with this and compared to like
a single point haptic device we might
have less high resolution in terms of
the spatial component it but by allowing
people to touch it with their whole
hands they're actually much more easily
able to understand what it is and the
shape so we think this is a promising
Direction but if we look at the types of
geometries that the people we were
working with are able to create with
this type of tactile display we can see
they're quite limited and so this was a
big issue that we we found but there is
this real benefit from having this tight
coupling of the iteration and so we
think this is a promising Direction
and and very promising in terms of this
notion of real-time iterative feedback
and also that people in the Blind and
Visually Impaired Community really do
want to be designers and makers of their
own you know basically technology and
this type of system can be very
empowering for them but you know there's
still these big issues in terms of
resolution so if we think about a
computer display that we might use being
very high resolution versus this pin
display that I'm showing here you know
there's a big gap in terms of the
resolution and potentially the under
understandability of that geometry and
then also in terms of access so if each
of those tactile displays it's still low
resolution costs upwards of six thousand
dollars that means that you know many
people can't have access to it as
opposed to you know 500 laptop that we
could use to teach cat so across these
different application areas we really
saw these big challenges in terms of
cost steel and resolution as well as
interaction techniques but I'm not going
to talk as much about that today and so
a lot of the work that we've done in the
past couple of years has been trying to
address or mitigate some of these issues
of of cost steel and resolution and
we've kind of taken two different
approaches uh to try to tackle that on
our group the first is in trying to
create new and novel Technical Solutions
uh Hardware solutions to solve that and
the sentient areas on kind of what we
call a kind of perceptual Illusions or
using basically perceptual engine
engineering to think about how do we
basically use the existing Hardware that
we have but maybe use some clever tricks
in terms of how we integrate information
together to improve the perceived
resolution and so I'm going to talk
about both of these areas
so the first area that I'll talk about
is on creating higher resolution tactile
displays and this has been kind of a big
challenge in the field of haptics for a
long time and there's sort of this big
trade-off or dichotomy between people
that are trying to make really high
bandwidth tactile displays versus people
that are trying to make kind of these
shape displays or tactile displays that
maybe don't need to move as fast or
maybe don't need to move at all and how
do we find this balance between the two
and so one of my former PhD students Kai
Zane started to think about ways in
which we could really try to push the
resolution if we trade off on that
bandwidth side of things and so if we
think about this design space or list of
design requirements for like the ideal
or ultimate tactile display there's a
lot of different things that we might
consider one of which is like what is
the necessary resolution and so we can
look to the haptics and psychophysics
literature for some intuition around
that you know basically if we think
about you know just statically touching
a shape something like that we need to
be in that one or 1.25 millimeter range
for us to be able to not really be able
to feel individual pins so you could
think about this idea of the retina
display that you might be familiar with
from Apple's marketing where you know if
you look at an iPhone today you can't
see where one pixel ends and the next
begins basically this two-point
discrimination threshold is kind of the
same concept and so we want to be in
that one to 1.25 millimeter range but
that's I would say a very generous uh
you know basically ballpark estimate
because actually if you start to move
your finger then you can basically feel
you know down to you know tens of
microns or below so you can feel you
know a single hair very easily but
that's relying much more on your you
know basically cutaneous information
from vibration and uh essentially
texture information but if we just think
about growth shape This 1.2 five
millimeters gets us pretty close
so as I said people have been trying to
work on this uh problem for a long time
and there's a lot of different
approaches in our own work we've used
like you know basically mechanical
linear actuators and also different
types of pneumatic actuators which have
again challenges in terms of scaling
these down as well as uh you know
basically the high cost of the actuators
and being able to scale those together
other people have created like
electromagnetic tactile displays but in
general those have some challenges as
you scale them down because the magnetic
electromagnetic fields start to bleed in
with each other so there's some
interesting work from Juan Zarate and
Herbert Shea in terms of thinking about
electromagnetic shielding for this but
they're still kind of on the centimeter
Steel type of size or other people using
electroactive polymers and again all of
these are really thinking about this
idea of you know how do we make a really
fast or a high bandwidth tactile display
and so our the intuition that I had was
okay let's not focus on the high
bandwidth aspect but instead what if we
had something that's much more like
e-ink where oh we're not changing it
very frequently we're going to kind of
refresh the whole the whole thing how do
we instead have uh maybe clutches or
breaks that we could engage or lock when
we need them to but then have one Global
actuator that might change everything
and so by trading off on this high
bandwidth or the temporal domain or
frequency domain and instead focusing on
the spatial what might we be able to do
and so the technology that we sort of
came to in terms of a good good
trade-off between this sort of high
Force density in terms of breaking or
clutching and then also the steel
ability is a electrostatic adhesion and
so many of you are probably familiar
with the electrostatic effect where you
know basically you have a balloon you
rub it on your hair and it sticks to
your head and so this has long been used
in different Industries for example
sample and like wafer chucking in the uh
to in the semiconductor industry
um and and paper handling and other
things and then over the past 15 or so
years it's really come into vote in the
robotics Community as well so probably
many of you are familiar with it but uh
it and also very commonly used in the
mems uh steel devices as well and so
basically we started to think about how
can we make these millimeter scale uh
you know basically uh High Force density
clutches and what are the different
techniques that we might need to to use
to do that and we think that this is a
promising technology for this type of uh
you know refreshable display and so
basically here we can see kind of an
example of one of these displays where
we have uh essentially a dielectric thin
film that we've then patterned with
these interdigitated electrodes that are
on the order of you know basically a
millimeter across and then we can
basically turn on an electric field that
then basically induces some charge on
these brass or different types of metal
pins and then locks them into place what
does this actually look like in action
okay great yeah yeah
so basically we can raise up at so it's
a refreshable display so essentially we
now we unlock all the pins we raise them
up and then as we move it down we lock
them into place and so the electrostatic
clutches can turn on and off very
quickly giving us very high Precision uh
in terms of linear positioning and are
relatively High force compared to their
size so again the basic operating
principle is that we have this you know
interdigitated electrode that's serving
as this clutch that's on one side of a
high dielectric constant thin film and
then on the other side there's a pin and
basically we induce opposite charge on
the pin and that basically creates this
electrostatic force and so a kind of
very simple model of how this
electrostatic force works is very
similar to The Parallel plate capacitor
equation where essentially you know the
things that matter are essentially the
the dielectric constant of the thin film
the contact area between the metal pin
and the dielectric film and the
electrodes on the other side the voltage
as well as the the film thickness and so
historically in kind of Robotics and
other applications people have really
pushed on the voltage as the thing to
kind of improve the the actuation force
here we have some challenges in doing
that because one we're dealing with
people and you know basically some of
these very high uh you know 10 kilovolt
types of range a very small amount of
current can actually be not very good
for people so that's one issue and then
the other issue is we want to have you
know not just one of these actuators we
don't have tens of thousands of these
actuators and so how can we have you
know very small and low-cost transistors
that allow us to you know steal this in
terms of production and so we ended up
trying to push more on the thin thinness
and also the high dielectric constant as
things that we could push on as opposed
to the voltage because of those two
range so this is kind of uh you know
basically what the actual device looks
like uh when we fabricate these and
using the UV laser cutter that marked
slab or actually get Allison okamura's
lab well I forget where it is now but
basically between Mark and Allison
exactly
um
shared facility which is great basically
that allows us to you know very easily
fabricate these and test out different
patterns and so we use pvdf which is a
high dielectric constant thin film and a
very small sheet of it and then we have
gold that's sputtered directly on it or
some other aluminum for example and then
we laser ablate off the the parts that
we don't want so the actuation principle
is is very simple in terms of you know
we have these clutches and then we lower
down the platform lock when the pins get
to the right place we turn on the clutch
and then we create the whole pattern and
then when we want to erase it or refresh
it we just turn them off and then move
the the pin up and down and so we can
get again very high spatial accuracy in
terms of the you know basically the
linear positioning of the height because
we can turn them turn on and off the the
clutches and about you know on the order
of 10 milliseconds or so
um
which allows us to have pretty high
spatial resolution
we've also done a lot of work on
quasi-static loading as well and
unfortunately the you know basically
other people as well so for example
Steve Collins lab has done a lot of work
on these electrostatic types of clutches
and also found that you know basically
the back of the envelope calculations
don't really end up matching very well
with performance because of the
effective contact area and so we've done
a lot of work also on data-driven
modeling for this but basically we think
these clutches uh you know on the order
of you know 50 to 100 grams of force for
the the areas that we're looking at
which you know is not that much force
but if we think about the contact force
that's necessary as you're exploring
something that's on the order of 51
grams of force and that would likely be
spread across multiple pins as well so
we think we're in the right right
ballpark for this and my current student
nahad who's there now is trying to work
on improving the the performance and
thinking about other things so we've
done some user testing as well to
explore how well these tactile displays
work and it seems like it's a promising
Direction and uh seems to be working
very well so we think this uh you know
basically these electrostatic pin
displays are kind of a promising
approach to really pushing the
resolution and low-cost aspects of these
types of refreshable tactile displays so
that's something that we're quite
excited about and we've been able to
achieve sort of this 1.5 or 1.7
millimeter pitch as well one of the
challenges with these types of displays
though is that they end up creating
these very discrete types of shapes
right and so it's possible that you know
we might want to have more continuous
shapes that could be approximated better
with some other method and also maybe
there's a way to do that where we trade
off you know basically uh and and
basically are able to have you know
basically more continuous shapes with
fewer number of actuators years and so
Ahad who recently had a paper that was
accepted to ikra that's on thinking
about how might we make these uh
basically more continuous shape displays
and what are techniques we could use to
sort of have sort of a monolithic
manufacturing process where we can kind
of create these in one go and so Ahad
has been working on thinking about kind
of the combination of electrostatic and
Electra adhesive actuation with oxidic
materials to be able to create basically
these shape changing continuous displays
where we're able to vary the curvature
of them by locking individual cells in
an oxidic Grid or an oxidic Network and
so here's an example of that shown here
and so basically the idea is that we
have you know work in oxidic skins where
we can basically have these different
patterns that can expand
basically differently based upon you
know how much uh you know strain there
is in the system them and what we're
doing is then locking some of these
cells in this exotic pattern and what
that does is it means that there's going
to be very different local strain
concentrations that end up as you
inflate this surface being able to
create different geometries and so
basically there's been exciting work in
the computer Graphics field as well as
in other areas on basically being able
to computationally design these oxidic
patterns so that you can then create
some arbitrary geometry that's beyond
sort of like what a developable surface
could be and uh our our kind of
contribution here is to think about oh
as opposed to being able to you know
essentially pre-plan and create a custom
oxidic pattern that could create some
dip given shape could we essentially
create a smart skin where we can change
that local amount that each cell can
open and close in real time or at run
time and so basically the way that we do
that is by having each object cell
essentially be electrostatic brake or
clutch that can you know basically
either open or close depending on how
much voltage we're applying across them
and so what this means is that we want
to have essentially an azetic pattern
with a very large surface area because
as I said before the electrostatic
forces basically proportional to the
amount of surface area that we have and
so essentially uh you know we've looked
at different patterns but this one here
you know again has a very large surface
area and so what we end up doing is
taking two of these sheets and then
rotating them off off phase so that
basically essentially there's a lot of
overlap between them and we can
essentially lock which parts will expand
and which parts work so here you get an
idea of what that single cell might look
like and so we have two
ah yeah so here you can see uh these
these sets expanding and Contracting and
so essentially we can as we pull on them
or inflate them they're opening up and
closing and we can basically uh turn on
the electrostatic adhesion to lock them
and allow them to not open up which
means that basically there's less
displacement and less strain in this
system so we've looked at different
types of combinations of of layers and
different materials as well
um and and are looking at you know
basically how do we then make this into
this monolithic system so again there's
these two sheets that are on top of each
other and then basically we create them
out of this flexible printed circuit
board and so that's really nice because
we can just go ahead and fabricate that
using off the shelf you know printed
circuit board techniques and then we
have one one sheet that's in this
orientation then a dielectric thin film
in between and then the other Flex PCB
that's uh on the on the next side as
well so then that's what the this sort
of 2D service here looks like and here
we're in DJing and locking between them
and you can see some of them start to
fail as well that I guess that was the
unlocked one here this region below is
locked and above is unlocked so you can
sort of see and then here's the the
locked region and at a certain point
it'll start to fail as well and so
basically we can again computationally
control which of those areas we want to
be locked in unlocked and that allows us
to create these different shapes and
then we have an inflated bladder that's
underneath it that we can then basically
inflate and that will then create this
Global shape change and so here's uh
kind of an example of this 100 Locked
which sort of creates this uh you know
basically a very uniform shape and then
now we're locking less and less of the
display to create different curvatures
if you can see like that so we think
that again this is kind of a promising
approach we're still looking for
basically uh oxidic patterns where we
didn't have higher uh you know amount of
strain and more basically curvature that
we can create then but we think this
again has some benefits in terms of
being able to really create and
manufacture this uh very quickly a
related project that was kind of in the
early stages is on kind of connecting
this idea of these continuous shape
displays with some of the work that I
showed at the beginning on these shape
changing robots where basically we want
to have these elastic Ridge shells so if
you think about in computer Graphics we
often have like nurbs surfaces which are
kind of combinations of these you know
different splines that are connected to
each other what if we do that in the
real world and so basically Sophia
weitzner and Winston law in our group
are trying to create these uh basically
robotic elastic grid shells that can
then again change their geometry in real
time this is a small one by one
prototype but here you can see we locked
one part of it and then we're able to
inject more material into it and create
this curvature there and so this is what
we're kind of aiming to do on the left
is create these you know basically inter
connected grid shells so where you can
in real time change their surface
um so these are some of the things we've
been doing in our group to think about
you know how can we push forward and
make these higher resolution uh you know
surface displays and I think we've had
some great promise in looking at
electrostatic adhesion as well as kind
of new approaches to making more
continuous service displays but I think
it's really clear to us and probably you
as well that the hardware will really
never perfectly render the real world
right the real world is so rich and and
very complex
um and and so I think there's this big
gap between that but the interesting
thing is that our perception is also
imperfect as well and so maybe we don't
need to have perfect Hardware when we're
considering these types of displays and
so the last part of my talk I want to
talk about some of the work we're doing
in terms of using Vizio haptic Illusions
to improve the perceived performance of
these types of tactile displays or other
types of shape displays so the first is
a work from my former PhD student
prostitute of tahi who's now starting at
at Princeton University next year that's
looking at this same problem of how we
might use our the fact that our Visio
are basically our visual perception is
often dominates our haptic perception
and so one way to illustrate this is you
know basically our proprioceptive system
is not very good and so if I am able to
like you know basically touch my fingers
together in front of my face I'm
actually often using my visual system to
really help me with that but if I try to
do it above my head I can sometimes get
it but you'll find that it's not as
accurate and so again that's because of
all the kind of Errors along the line in
terms of you know our different joints
and the different mechanoreceptors that
we have but our proprioceptive system
has more noise and air than our visual
system and therefore our you know brains
when we're thinking about integrating
this multi-sensory integration sorry
integrating it's multi-sensory
information tend to rely on our visual
system and so as I mentioned before
there's many of these limitations of
these shape displays that I talked about
in terms of low spatial resolution
limited display size or low actuation
speed and the Intuition or Insight that
uh parasu had was oh how can we leverage
this fact that our appropriate receptive
system isn't very good to sort of
increase the perceived resolution and
this really uh kind of essentially uh
Builds on a technique from the field of
virtual reality that's called redirected
touch some of you might be familiar with
the idea of redirected walking where
again we can kind of steer people in
virtual reality by having some slight
offset between where you are in the real
world and where you see you are where
you see yourself or where you see your
hand in the virtual scene and so what we
can do is essentially apply some small
virtual offset as I'm reaching that
basically makes it seem like my hand as
I move straight is moving to the left
and my basically visual motor system
will basically compensate for that and
make my hand move to the right in the
real world to basically compensate for
that bias or shift to the left and so we
can basically computationally steer
where a person's hand is going by
applying these offsets in the virtual
world and by leveraging that redirected
touch effect we're able to address some
of these different aspects of low
spatial resolution and low actuation
speed and so I'll talk about some of the
ways in which we're doing that here
uh using angle redirection scaling up
and and vertical redirection as well so
you might be familiar with this idea of
anti-aliasing or the aliasing effect
that happens when we look at graphical
display this aliasing effect is actually
also very pronounced in these tactile
displays as well and so one way that we
were trying to mitigate this low
resolution is by trying to essentially
get rid of this aliasing that happens
when you display a vertical or sorry a
diagonal line and so if we see here as
we move along the surface here uh you
know basically we have this kind of
again aliasing effect that you can feel
these bumps as well and so what if
instead we could redirect you so that
you're moving along a straight line
which is very doesn't have that aliasing
problem but in the virtual world you
think you're moving along this diagonal
line and so again by applying this
slight offset between where your hand is
in the real world and where it is in the
virtual scene we can make you touch
different areas of the display and not
be able to to realize it or perceive it
in terms of you know the overall
resolution of the device you know we can
think about the number of pixels or
taxes that you're in contact with as you
move over a surface right and so one of
the challenges right is if we have a
small object that we're rendering on a
tactile display of a fixed resolution
then you're not going to encounter that
many taxes As you move along the surface
so again what if we could change this
essentially control the display Ratio or
utilizes this offset between where my
real hand is in my virtual hand is and
in the virtual scene render a small
object but in the real world render a
larger off object of the same version
and we can render it in higher
resolution so again we can change the
the ratio between where I'm interacting
in the the real world where I'm
interacting in the virtual world and and
leverage that to improve the perceived
resolution and we've done this also for
things like extending the the height of
the display the workspace limitations of
it and other things like that as well so
here you can see as I'm moving up I have
some fixed amount of range that I can
move up and then here we're able to
again offset where you think your hand
is in the virtual scene and so you can
think that the you know basically the
tactile display has larger pins or you
know then we can actually create with
these displays there's some we've run a
lot of psychophysical studies to find
what these thresholds are and also find
that when we display these underneath
the amount basically when we display an
offset underneath that threshold
essentially people perceive it as being
higher resolution without noticing that
it's uh there but we've also found some
interesting effects in the difference
between active versus passive Touch
where in the Active touch conditions
that's where you're moving your hand as
well so for example in that angle
redirection uh we can't offset people's
hands as much as we can in the passive
touch condition where for example the
motor is moving your hand where we can
offset people more and so again that has
to do with kind of the uh you know
forward model that people have uh in
their sensory motor system in terms of
you know basically uh my predictions of
where my hand might be and so I'm more
willing to allow things to have noise
and and there to be more air when I'm
being moved versus I'm moving myself as
well so we've looked at ways in which we
can leverage this to create different
types of applications such as you know
improving the resolution or or you know
again increasing the vertical
redirection as well but as you can see
from those types of systems you know
these Illusions really only work in this
small area of the display and so another
set of work that we've been doing is
trying to improve the kind of
scalability of how we might apply these
to a much larger area and create
essential what are called encountered
type haptic displays that might operate
over a larger region so we put this
types of haptic displays tactile
displays on you know a robotic arm and
then when we reach out the robotic
device can be there in time but one of
the challenges with this type of
approach of encountered type haptic
devices is that oftentimes the device
has some limitations as well right so
the device may arrive late or it might
be out of the workspace of that robotic
system so I want to touch something up
here but the robot is only down there
and so again there's a number of
challenges with these encounter type
haptic devices in terms of different
reachability issues that lead to these
uncertain spatial discrepancies which
really kind of affect people's perceived
performance of these devices so we've
done a few things in this area to
improve the essentially the the ability
for these devices to work by essentially
redirecting your hand to the reachable
area of the robotic system
great
okay great so anyway basically we can do
some cool things in terms of this uh you
know redirection to guide people into
different people's space and we've also
done some interesting work on trying to
apply uh basically model predictive
control to basically run this in real
time to improve the perceived
performance using a model of human
reaching and sensory integration so I
think that I'll conclude there with just
one
short statement if I didn't find it
which is that you know we started out
this work really thinking about how real
does haptics need to be and I think
where our group is going is is really
trying to think more about how real this
haptics need to seem and really trying
to leverage this sensory motor control
perspective to optimize both the
hardware and the software together so
I'd like to think you know my PhD
students and postdocs in my lab that
contribute to this work as well as our
funding sources and I guess I'd be happy
to answer any questions uh yeah I
thought it was until 1 30. so my
apologies on that Mark yeah so thanks so
much
foreign